all right so as we continue to in some
sense wait to see what ultimately
happens with criminal charges against
the failed former president Donald Trump
he has returned to his Mar-A-Lago home
for the first time since the now
Infamous search warrant that was served
the raid as many call it
um in Mar-A-Lago and Donald Trump is
absolutely Furious he's raging that the
FBI allegedly didn't take their shoes
off uh when they went into his house and
all sorts of other crazy things there's
just a lot going on and some of the
cultists were up all night waiting to
welcome Donald Trump trump at Mar-A-Lago
so let's go through all of it a Business
Insider reports Donald Trump is back at
Mar-A-Lago and raging about FBI agents
not taking off their shoes while
searching his bedroom Donald Trump
published a message to truth social also
known as Troth Central where he said
quote
arrived in Florida last night and had a
long and detailed chance to check out
the scene of yet another government
crime the FBI's raid and break-in of my
home Mar-A-Lago remember it was not a
crime and it was not a break-in the FBI
showed up with a search warrant uh FBI
director signed off on it attorney
general signed off on it a judge signed
off on it perfectly legal Trump going on
to say I guess they don't think there is
a fourth amendment anymore and to them
there isn't of course there is no Fourth
Amendment violation because of the
things I just mentioned Trump continuing
in any event after what they have done
the place will never be the same it was
quote ransacked now why does Trump put
ransacked in quotes does he mean it
wasn't really ransacked
because when you put it in quotes it
almost suggests he doesn't think it was
ransacked anyway and in Far different
condition than the way I left it many
agents and they didn't even take off
their shoes in my bedroom
nice nice now to give you a sense of the
level of cultishness that's going on
here
there were people waiting for Trump's
arrival
in the middle of the night lining the
street check this out I'm coming back to
his Florida home Sunday night dozens of
his supporters waiting along the bridge
on Southern Boulevard waiting doing
their Flags cheering as he drove through
yeah this is a cult
this is a cult and we it's not even like
I'm necessarily passing a value judgment
I mean I do in other segments obviously
I think it's an absurd cult based on
lies and confusion but
it's it's a cult and if you we've spoken
to cult experts and that is indeed what
it is there's another video this one is
from
um this one was from yesterday afternoon
which was hours before Trump even got
back real America's voice American
Sunrise was there this was at 8 A.M and
you see all these people holding crosses
some guy dressed as Trump American flags
Trump Flags other paraphernalia a sign
that said Trump won honk for Trump
um just all sorts of different
characters because this you know they're
waiting to welcome a potential criminal
that's what they're doing here now my
prediction is
that with Donald Trump back at
Mar-A-Lago
and understand there's two parts to this
one Trump's back at Mar-A-Lago which he
considers the scene of the crime or
whatever I think it'll be it'll trigger
him more than being in New York
um being back there and that will
probably lead to a particularly unhinged
Trump but also Mar-A-Lago has become a
sort of like uh it's almost like the
wedding at the beginning of the
Godfather where all of the acolytes and
brown nosers and suck ups are making
their pilgrimages so to speak and that's
what they do at Mar-A-Lago Trump hosts
people everything everybody from you
know Kyle Rittenhouse to other
right-wing Heroes yeah I know and so
it's likely I would say that Trump's
visitors are going to fire him up and
give him ideas he'll probably be meeting
with lawyers and so I expect it's going
to be a really really crazy week
um one other little note on what's been
going on with Trump lately there has
been a preview released by Newsmax of
what they're calling a special and this
is a special in which right-wing actor
John Voigt who's the father of actress
Angelina Jolie
um John Voigt who really has not seemed
with it for a while in terms of his
connection to reality he actually wept
during the interview or maybe wept is
too much he cried so this is something
else we're going to be watching out for
very very closely and she came in and
you said I hear you have a little bit of
a difficult
and she said well I have some cancer
issues
and
see I'm getting emotional to you this is
from the YouTube you keep saying the
champ because you can't watch The Champ
without crying well I can't I can't just
go through this story without crying
and you said I'll take care yeah
so uh a visibly emotional Jon Voight
overcome with how
good of a person and genuine and caring
and all of these other things that we
have no evidence for uh Donald Trump is
so that's the latest there and we'll
keep an eye on Mar-A-Lago this week
could be could be quite a week